>>> THIS MORNING UTED NATIONS
SECRETARY GENEL ABILITY KNOW
GUTIERREZ ARRIVINGN PAKISTAN
APPEALING TO THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY FOR HELP IN RESPONSE
TO THE DEVASTATING FLOODS THAT
HAVE HIT THAT COUNTRY KILLING
ALMOST 1,400 PEOPLE, SWEEPING
AWAY ENTIRE VILLAGES, ROADS,
BRIDGES AND LIVESTOCK.
CLARISSA WARD JOINS US LIVE FROM
A SHELTER FOR THE DISPLACED IN
KARACHI.
I IMAGINE THERE IS SO MUCH OF A
NEED RIGHT NOW.
>> Reporter: WELL, JOHN, YOU
HEARD THE SECRETARY GENERAL, HE
SAID THE SUPPORT THAT THEY HAVE
RECEIVED SO FAR FOR THE U.N. IS
JUST A DROP IN THE OCEAN OF WHAT
IS NEEDED.
WE ARE HERE AT ONE OF THESE
MAKESHIFT CAMPS, THEY HAVE
SPRUNG UP ALL OVER THIS AREA TO
TRY TO ACCOMMODATE THE MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN PUSHED
FROM THEIR HOMES.
YOU CAN SEE IT IS A DESPERATE
SITUATION HERE.
THIS USED TO BE A GIRLS SCHOOL,
PEOPLE ARE SLEEPING ON THE
FLOOR, THERE ARE FLIES
EVERYWHERE.
THERE ARE 50 FAMILIES SHARING A
SINGLE BATHROOM, A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO
HAVE BEEN HERE FOR WEEKS,
THEY'RE SICK MANY OF THEM.
THEY ARE LUCKY TO GET FOOD, BUT
SIMPLY PUT, THIS IS NOT A
SUSTAINABLE SITUATION AND THIS
IS ALSO AN INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE
SITUATION FOR THE GOVERNMENT OF
PAKISTAN, THE ARMY CHIEF TELLING
THE U.N. SECRETARY GENERAL THAT
THEY HAVE SPENT ROUGHLY $30
BILLION, THAT NUMBER IS ONLY
GOING TO GO UP BECAUSE, GUESS
WHAT, JOHN, THE PEOPLE WE ARE
TALKING TO HERE SAY THAT EVEN
WHEN THOSE FLOODWATERS RECEDE
THEY DON'T WANT TO GO BACK TO
THEIR HOMES BECAUSE THEY'RE TOO
FEARFUL THAT THIS WILL HAPPEN
AGAIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Tra
>> Reporter: THE WATERS ARE NOT
SUBS
SUBSIDING.
THE CITY HAD BEEN A SANCTUARY
FOR SOME OF THE MORE THAN 6
MILLION PEOPLE DISPLACED BY THE
FLOODS IN THIS REGION.
NOW THE MAIN HIGHWAY HAS BECOME
A WATERWAY, SMALLER ROADS INTO
THE CITY ARE CHOKED WITH
TRAFFIC.
YOU CAN SEE THERE'S JUST A
STEADY STREAM OF VEHICLES
POURING INTO THIS AREA.
THESE ARE ALL PEOPLE WHO ARE
DESPERATELY TRYING TO ESCAPE
THEIR VILLAGES WHICH ARE NOW
COMPLETELY SUBMERGED UNDER
WATER.
PAKISTAN IS RESPONSIBLE FOR LESS
THAN 1% OF THE WORLD'S EMI
EMISSIONS, BUT IT IS PAYING A
STIFF PRICE FOR GLOBAL WARMING.
HEAVY MONSOON RAINS AND MELTING
GLACIERS HAVE LEFT NEARLY A
THIRD OF THIS COUNTRY UNDER
WATER, WIPING OUT VILLAGES LIKE
THIS ONE.
WHEN THE FLOODS HIT RESIDENTS
CARRIED WHATEVER THEY COULD SAVE
TO A NARROW STRIP OF LAND BY THE
ROADSIDE.
SO THIS IS HOW YOU'RE LIVING
NOW.
LIVING IN A MAKESHIFT SHELTER
FOR OVER A WEEK, THERE IS NO GAS
TO COOK WHATEVER FOOD THEY HAVE
LEFT, OUTSIDE AID HAS YET TO
ARRIVE AND THE PROSPECTS OF
RETURNING HOME ANYTIME SOON ARE
DIM.
IT'S VERY PAINFUL TO SEE, BUT
WHERE CAN WE GO, HE SAYS.
THIS IS MY ANCESTRAL VILLAGE.
A FEW MILES DOWN THE ROAD LOCALS
ARE RACING TO STAY AHEAD OF THE
RELENTLESS WATERS.
THE GOVERNMENT LEFT THEM SAND TO
MAKE SANDBAGS, BUT LITTLE OTHER
ASSISTANCE.
OVERSTRETCHED BY THE
UNPRECEDENTED SCALE OF THE
CRISIS.
SO JUST SO I UNDERSTAND, YOU ARE
BUILDING UP THESE DIKES TO TRY
TO STOP THAT WATER FROM
COMPLETELY DESTROYING YOUR
VILLAGE?
THERE'S TOO MUCH WATER COMING
IN, HE TELLS US, AND WE ARE
AFRAID OF IT.
HE'S SHOWING HOW DEEP IT IS.
CAN YOU SEE HOW DEEP THAT IS?
ONE MAN PLUNGES INTO THE FLOOD
WATER TO SHOW HOW HIGH THE
WATERS ARE.
THE FLOODING HERE HAS NOW
REACHED ITS CRUELEST PHASE, THE
DAYS NO LONGER BRING RAIN, BUT
NOR DO THEY BRING RELIEF.
AND FOR THE MANY WHO HAVE LOST
EVERYTHING, THERE IS NOTHING TO
DO BUT WAIT.
JOHN AND BRIANNA, THE U.N.
SECRETARY-GENERAL SAID TO THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY THAT
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE AND MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE NOW, NOT JUST
OUT OF SOLIDARITY, BUT OUT OF
JUSTICE.
YOU HEARD IN THAT PIECE PAKISTAN
CONTRIBUTING A MICROSCOPIC
AMOUNT OF THE WORLD'S EMITTING
GASES, PAYING THE HEAVIEST
PRICE.
GUTERRES ALSO SAID THE WORLD'S
ATTITUDE TOWARD COMBATTING
CLIMATE CHANGE AMOUNTS TO
INSANITY AT THIS STAGE,
COLLECTIVE SUICIDE IF THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY DOES NOT
GET ON BOARD TO TRY TO DEAL WITH
THIS COUNTRY AND SUPPORT
COUNTRIES LIKE PAKISTAN THAT ARE
PAYING THE HEAVIEST PRICE.
>> YEAH, AND WATCHING IT UNFOLD.
HOW MANY UNPEOPLE IT IS
AFFECTING HERE.
WHAT ARE THESE FAMILIES TELLING
YOU, CLARISSA?
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
BEEN SITTING HERE TALKING TO A
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT FAMILIES AND
EVERY ONE OF THEM HAS A HORROR
STORY TO TELL.
THEY ARE IN A STATE OF ACUTE
POVERTY.
THEIR HOUSES HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED.
WE SPOKE TO ONE FAMILY WHO SOLD
ALL THEIR LIVESTOCK TO MAKE IT
HERE TO KARACHI, AND NOW THEY'RE
SUBSISTING ON THE HANDOUTS THEY
GET TWICE A DAY, THEY SAY WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO HAVE THAT FOOD, TO
KEEP OUR FAMILY ALIVE, BUT IN
THE LONG RUN, THIS IS NOT A
SUSTAINABLE SLUOLUTION.
WHAT I MENTIONED BEFORE AND WHAT
HAS BEEN SO STRIKING TALKING TO
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE, THEY
DON'T WANT TO STAY HERE, BUT
THEY DON'T WANT TO GO BACK HOME
BECAUSE THEY SAY UNTIL WE SEE
MEANINGFUL CHANGE IN TERMS OF
COMBATTING THE COMBAT CRISIS AND
AS LONG AS WE CONTINUE TO SEE
THESE TERRIBLE EPIC FLOODS EVERY
SINGLE YEAR, WHY WOULD WE GO
BACK, WHY WOULD WE INVEST IN
REBUILDING OUR HOMES WHEN WE
COULD FIND OURSELVES IN THE
EXACT SAME SITUATION IN ONE
YEAR'S TIME, BRIANNA?
>> YEAH, AND IT IS AN
UNDERSTANDABLE FEAR.
CLARISSA WARD, THANK YOU FOR
THAT REPORT.